chuckling life assuming someone would be
a good seal officer would you suggest
they go enlisted first get experience
then become an officer would you suggest
that or the other choice would be just
go straight officer commissioned so
right I guess we have both of those
examples here right I was enlisted first
leaf went straight commissioned out of
the Naval Academy and I think we're
probably gonna pray to say pretty much
the same thing here in terms of to me it
doesn't really matter it doesn't really
matter where you get your commission
from it doesn't really matter if you get
a commission it doesn't really matter
there's guys in the SEAL Teams there's
enlisted senior leaders that are awesome
examples they're awesome leaders they
change people's lives they have a huge
impact on the battlefield there's
obviously officers that do the same
thing I think you know I had an
incredibly lucky career and I had a
great career and I wouldn't change any
part of it at all you know I was lucky
enough to to be an enlisted guy and do
multiple deployments as an enlisted guy
and then be an officer and do multiple
deployments as an officer and it was
great and I wouldn't change any part of
it and I know plenty of guys that were
officers their whole career and they
wouldn't change any of that and I know
plenty of guys I wouldn't listen to guys
their whole career and they wouldn't
change any of that
so I think the important thing is think
about what piece of the puzzle you want
to fit into and what you really want
your your expertise in your job to be I
don't what you think life you wish you
would have done some time as an e dog as
a sled dog for sure I mean look there's
there's a part of me that certainly
always wishes that but look I think it's
it's just a different it's a different
job you're gonna always as an officer
straight out of a commissioned source I
had to lean on those I had to lean on
those Chiefs I had to lean on those
leading petty officers those folks who
had it
who could help me and guide me and you
know no matter who you are you're not
gonna have it all figured out and it's
something that Jocko you talk about
often we talk about often and when we
work with companies so having run our
leadership course what we call the
junior officer training course and every
single seal officer that graduates from
you know from every commissioning source
that graduates from the seal training
pipeline goes through this course
there's about a five week course four
week of classroom one week of field
training exercise where we're kind of
out in the field and putting these guys
through some some challenges and I try
led that for two years I just talked at
that course and I think we put on one
hundred and thirtysomething officers do
that and the best officer we had some
great officers that went through that
and probably the best officer I put
through was a prior listed seal we had
some officers that struggled and
probably the guy who struggled the most
was another prior enlisted seal both
these guys have been prior less than a
commissioned officer so it just goes to
show you that you've every source
whether it's a Naval Academy
whether it's prior listed and going to
seem an admiral program whether it's
coming in through OCS Officer Candidate
School or in ROTC you know at
universities
you've got outstanding people that come
out of those those commissioning sources
you got some people that aren't that
good that come out of this commission
resources so it's about you and and I
think it's it's kind of immaterial
mm-hmm the physical part is pretty
important right going in well of course
you got to have some level of
athleticism but it's not the two of you
yeah it's not it just it just if you
keep yes show up and be ready to make it
through the training but that's right
that has next nothing to do with your
ability to lead people of course you
have to be physically fit you have to be
able to I mean there's no doubt you have
to be physically fit yeah that's like
that's like a ground base no doubt about
it so if you don't have that you're not
even close mmm so everybody that is
gonna be the leadership position in the
SEAL Teams it's basically a beard gotcha
okay yeah I'm them for whatever reason
thinking just to be a seal okay cool all
right next question
chocolate lace
your books principles universal or only
for us audience we work with audiences
anywhere they apply to any in anywhere I
mean across the world human beings in
any kind of leadership capacity in any
capacity and you know business or life
and Jacqueline I've actually done a lot
of work internationally as well so we've
done I've spoken to groups in Europe
I've worked with leadership training
groups from China and and spoken in
Canada across the world where leaders or
leaders there do the same kind of
problems same kind of issues is not
Universal only applies to America it
applies anywhere yeah and I what I found
is and junky always talk about like how
its relationships building relationships
up and down the chain of command
so and really that relationships theme
is it's kind of everything in life where
whether it's like your friends or your
spouse husband or wife or whatever in
the teams or in business right so
relationships apply to everybody in the
whole world no matter what culture US or
otherwise so each different type of
person right were the people who read
your his book is it isn't always gonna
be a military guy or a business guy but
I just I just had a friend who sent me a
picture he was in Frankfurt Germany
walking through out of his hotel and
there's a guy sitting in the lobby I
like the coffee bar reading extreme
ownership yeah Germany so I mean this is
it's everywhere and and I think leaders
who seek to be better I mean this this
book is for them the principles in this
book are for them and a lot of the
companies we work with they even if
they're based in the US they have they
have ties to other countries
manufacturing plants in Mexico or China
or you know across the world and and do
business across the Atlantic Ocean cost
the Pacific Ocean I'm it's a very
international interconnected world out
there and and I mean there's most the
comments were working with these days
have have offices in South America or
Asia or Europe and
they're kind of worldwide this could and
this is gonna sound kind of crazy but
this could easily be a relationship
counseling guide as well well obviously
if you take extreme ownership of your
relationship and you you realize where
where it could be you that could be the
problem in your relationship yes
now that being said echo Charles this
will not turn into a relationship
podcast not a marriage we're here to
talk about war you're not gonna be dr.
Laura yes it's not happening they're not
happening
good try